so yeah so so I'm gonna talk about joint
work with the shenoy lab at Stanford
primarily carried out by these very
talented graduate students eran Gao and
Eric Troutman and and also other you
know these are the other members of my
lab and members of critius lab were
involved in the work and the funding and
so on so what I'd like to try to address
as a major conceptual elephant that I
think resides within almost all work in
systems neurophysiology which is the
following how can we record you know
order say a hundred neurons in regions
deep within the brain far from the
sensory or motor periphery like say
hippocampus prefrontal cortex and so
forth and obtain scientifically
interpret over results that relate
neural activity to behavior and
cognition this is actually quite
remarkable considering these brain
regions contain ten to the six to ten to
the ninth neurons five orders of
magnitude more than we can record and
this remarkable observation goes beyond
simply science and into clinical
practice for example we can create
reasonably good prosthetic devices by
decoding based on the activity of order
a hundred neurons so the question is how
has systems neuroscience been as
successful as it has been in such an
under sampled measurement regime or
could it potentially be worse than that
could we be completely misleading
ourselves and our view of neural circuit
computation could dramatically change as
we start to record more and more neurons
so without an adequate theory of neural
dimensionality dynamics and measurement
it's hard to even adjudicate between
these two possible extremes of relative
success or or
abysmal failure at the level of
recordings that we're doing so lest you
think that that maybe there's an
experimental solution given given you
know the brain initiative and so on and
so forth in terms of pushing us to
record more neurons you know there has
indeed been a kind of Moore's Law
exponential growth in the number of
neurons that we can record from the
brain with a doubling time of about
seven point four years so currently we
can record about a hundred to a thousand
neurons mammalian circuits controlling
complex behaviors contain 10 to the 10
to the 6 to 10 to the ninth neurons
so just extrapolating this exponential
growth trend it would take us about a
hundred twenty two years to get five
orders of magnitude more neurons none of
us will be alive well maybe some of the
grad students might be but none of the
faculty will be alive in the Rob there's
other Moore's Law advances that might be
required for that in other regimes of
health so what we really need is we need
a theory of neural data analysis that
tells us how and when statistical
analyses applied to an infinitesimal
subset of neurons do indeed reflect the
collective dynamics of the much larger
on absurd unobserved circuit they're
embedded in that's what we'd really like
to have you know okay so so what's an
example of the type of problem that
we're faced with so I'll be talking
about work with with krishna's lab so
here's some example data from christians
lab these are recordings of single
neurons recorded from a monkey monkeys
motor cortex and dorsal premotor cortex
while the monkey is reaching to several
different directions at two different
reach extents and two different speeds
okay so this is neuron one two and three
and as you can see there's an incredible
amount of complexity and heterogeneity
in in this dynamics these are three
neurons but there's about a hundred more
neurons like this and so the natural
question is how do we try to extract
insights from this kind of large-scale
data how are such datasets analyzed an
extremely common method of approach is
dimensionality reduction so you know a
very simple form of that would be for
example principal components analysis
but in many forms of dimensionality
reduction you can think about the
pattern of neural activity across the
set of recorded neurons as a pattern
that exists at a certain point in time
as you go through the experiment you'll
occur many you'll encounter many many
patterns of neural activity over time
and that sets up you know the space of
neural activity patterns explored by the
monkey during the time course of the
experiment most dimensionality reduction
methods especially the linear ones tried
to decompose the set of all patterns
accounted during the experiment in in a
in terms of a time-dependent
your combination of a set of basis
patterns right so in principal
components analysis these would be the
principal components and oftentimes what
you find in many many experiments that
you only need a small number of basis
patterns to explain a large amount of
variance in the data and so once you
have these betas basis patterns and the
decomposition coefficients you can plot
the you can plot the neural dynamics not
in neuron space where each axis would be
the firing rate of one neuron but in
pattern space where each axis is the is
the weight associated one of with one of
the basis neural activity patterns and
this yields sort of a dynamical portrait
of how the circuit computes and and so
this has been applied in many many
pieces of work and often times these
dynamical portraits really are quite
insightful and tell us a lot about what
the circuit is doing for example in
dimensionality reduction on neural
activity from the locus Sentinel lobe
from Jim Lawrence lab this work told us
that the the Alpha the antenna lobe
actually contains a lot of information
about odor along the transient path to
the fixed point which was kind of
intriguing in a somatosensory
discrimination task dimensional
reduction revealed that somatosensory
cortex actually mostly encoded for the
passage of time and only a much smaller
amount of variance was actually devoted
to discriminating between the different
frequencies that the monkey had to
discriminate between in order to perform
success from the task in recent work
from the Chenoa newson labs the very
curvature of neural activity patterns or
neural dynamics revealed the existence
of a novel method for context-dependent
integration and actually if you record
from the entire brain of the zebrafish
you can actually fit most of the
dynamics into three dimensions you know
so that's kind of an intriguing
observation so so this is what's done
but a natural question is should we
trust any of this given that they were
derived from recording so few neurons so
the fundamental conceptual questions I'd
like to ask are can we trust these
dynamic portraits more particularly how
would the shape of these portraits or
change if we recorded more neurons would
their dimension
the increase if we recorded more neurons
why is the dimensionality so low that's
actually one of the most salient
observations and multi-electron
recordings is often times you can get
away with less than 10 dimensions to
explain a lot of the variance in the
data despite the fact that you've
recorded hundreds of neurons and this is
a question that really extends beyond
the writ of Neuroscience what if
anything at all
can we large learn about large dynamical
networks of such an overwhelming level
of under sampling and in particular
could we actually obtain a predictive
theory of experimental design that can
tell us how many neurons we should
record and how should this number depend
on properties of neural activity and the
task and so that's the kind of things
we'd like to try to get out let me
before I kind of tell you about the
results let me just give you the
take-home messages first so that gives
you a framework for thinking about what
I'm going to tell you about so we're
gonna soso core to this the first part
of this talk will be a mathematical
definition of neural task complexity
it's say it's a measure of complexity
that takes into account both the
complexity of neural dynamics and the
complexity of the task that the system
is asked to perform and with this
definition in hand we can show that the
dimension at that the dimensionality of
neural activity is bounded from above by
this neural task complexity measure and
it turns out that motor cortical data is
actually as high dimensional as possible
given that the neural task complexity
imposed by the task and this suggests
that in future recording experiments if
you were to simply record more neurons
without increasing the complexity of the
task you will not obtain a richer
datasets at least as measured by the
dimensionality because this inequality
is already saturated and furthermore on
the side of neural measurement so about
the shape of these neural trajectories
from which we make scientific inferences
we develop conditions to accurately
recover these dynamic portraits and we
come up with a novel conceptual
connection between the act of doing
neurophysiology and the theory of random
projections which is a scenario which is
a relatively recent a branch of machine
learning / applied math
and what this says is that what this
tells us is that we can't actually trust
most of our past results the existing
dynamic portraits are likely to be
accurate despite recording so few
neurons so it's an optimistic message
but also it has some design some methods
for thinking about experimental design
in the future which we'll get okay so so
of course key to all of this is the
notion of how the task constrains the
dimensionality of neural data and in
particular this quantity called neural
task complexity so how might this occur
let me just give you some intuition
before I give you the result let's say
that we have a relatively simple
colloquially speaking simple task where
a monkey is reaching from point A to
point B okay now we record hundreds of
neurons from the monkey's brain and we
can look at the trial averaged neural
activity patterns as a function of time
or distance into the reach okay so these
are for example a cartoon neural
dynamics right and we can plot this
neural dynamics as a trajectory in a
high dimensional firing rate space where
each axis is the firing rate of one
neuron now the key is that the task
lasts for a finite amount of time or the
reach goes a finite distance and also a
neural activity doesn't change
infinitely fast it has an
autocorrelation timescale tau so you
have to wait an amount of time tau
before the pattern of neural activity
changes appreciably this can all be
formalized or more precisely but I'm
just talking intuitively now so if you
think about this neural trajectory you
have to wait at an amount of time tau
before it points in a different
direction and therefore explores a
different dimension wait another amount
of time tau before you explore another
dimension so then the maximum number of
dimensions you could explore given the
simplicity of the task and the
smoothness of neural dynamics is the
total amount of time the task takes
divided by the autocorrelation time so
this is what you'd expect dimensionality
to be proportional to let's imagine a
slightly more complicated task where the
monkey is reaching two different
directions at and so then the manifold
of behavioral States explored by the
monkey is just a cylinder index by time
into the reach or distance into the
reach and the angle of the reach
and the trial average neural data is
just fundamentally an embedding of the
cylinder into this same neural activity
pattern space okay so how do we think
about the maximum number of dimensions
you could possibly explore given this
kind of a task and smoothness well what
I said for time and a fixed angle also
holds for angle at a fixed time right so
if I walk around the task space around a
certain cylinder here I'll walk around a
certain cylinder here the total angles
that can explore a 2pi but again neural
activity patterns have a spatial
autocorrelation length now as you move
around an angle ural activity patterns
don't change infinitely fast you have to
move an amount of time Delta before you
can explore a different dimension so the
number of dimensions you can explore
across one circle here is 2pi over Delta
now if you put it all together and you
assume that these neural activity
patterns are maximally d correlated so
that there are no correlations across
time and angle then each time you move a
little bit of time and a little bit of
angle you're exploring a completely new
and your elective 'ti pattern so we
expect that we expect that the maximal
number of dimensions you could possibly
explore is the product of the number you
can explore across time and a number you
can explore across angle and so this
would be the the intuition I've been
fast and loose about the constants here
but I just wanted to tell you that we
have a theory that in very general says
if you can parametrize a task by a set
of task parameters for example angles
speed direction so a reach extent and so
on and these task parameters vary over
certain ranges for example capital T and
2pi in the fur in the simple examples
and neural activity has some of these
correlation lengths across each of these
task parameters then we can define the
neural task complexity is the volume of
the task manifold divided by the volume
of an autocorrelation cell and there's
some constant involved ok so a theory
provides a quantitative way to extract
the neural correlation lengths and the
proportionality constant C such that we
can prove a theorem which is that the
neural dimensionality is less than the
of our task complexity of course the
number of neurons you recorded where the
measure of dimensionality that we're
using this is a bit technical is that
it's just the participation ratio of the
eigen spectrum of the neuron by neuron
covariance matrix which roughly
corresponds to so this is the mesh this
is the participation ratio these are
eigen values this is a number that's one
if all the activities concentrated along
a single mode and it's n if all the
activities concentrated along evenly
across all the modes or all the neurons
and it smoothly interpolates between
those two extremes and for a wide
variety of spectra that you actually see
in neuroscience that corresponds to
about 70 percent of variance explained
there's nothing magical about the number
70 if we came up with a theory for a
slightly larger constant times d this
would be a larger fraction okay so so
this is this is the nature of the theory
so it connects three two things the
volume of the task manifold which is a
measure of the task complexity with the
smoothness of neural activity so we call
it this neural task complexity measure
and okay so now how do we use this to
sort of reinterpret existing data so I'm
going to apply this to the reaching data
from the shinola so this is again the
task it's just a delayed reach task
where a go queue appears or target
appears the go queue is marked by the
disappearance of the central square and
then the monkey moves during the delay
period activity is largely stationary so
we're just analyzing the the dynamical
activity from the disappearance of the
go queue to the acquisition of the
target that's the that's the period of
time that we're we're looking at and
we're we're looking at data from an
array centered on the dorsal premotor
cortex this is one data set where the
monkey was reaching in eight different
directions and there were 109 very well
isolated neurons and we have another
data set where this monkey is reaching
in you know a few more task conditions
and we get sort of similar results here
oops sorry so I'm going to just focus
for this talk on this on this data set
so just to review some numbers in
primary motor cortex there are 100
million neurons connecting about 650
skeletal muscles in these Express
it's a hundred order 100 neurons were
recorded and the pca dimensionality
roughly 70% of a number of principal
components you need to keep 70% of
variance explained across all eight
reaches is only seven all right the
number the the number required to keep
to account for just one reach is only
three point three so these numbers are
relatively small compared to the number
of recorded neurons and the question is
why where do these numbers come from in
some sense the dimensionality of a data
set is a fundamental descriptor of its
complexity and we have a theory for a
quantitative theory for why these
numbers take the value that they do so
so that's uh so let's apply it to this
data so then what what is the neural
task complexity for this data set so it
turns out that for a single region it
was about 4.2 and across all all all the
other reaches it was 10 right so what
this suggests is that the simplicity of
the task combined with the smoothness of
ural activity patterns essentially
imposes a stringent upper bound on
neural dimensionality and the neural
dimensionality achieved by the
experiment actually is close to these
upper bounds so in essence we shouldn't
think of this data set as simple simply
because the dimensionality is small
relative the number of neurons we should
think of motor cortex is essentially
wiggling around as much as it possibly
can in order to implement this in order
to implement these reaches subject to
the constraints on the speed of neural
activity the speed with which you can
change so so yeah so the implication
number one is neural dimensionality
shouldn't be really thought of as small
but almost as large as possible given
task constraints and smoothness and it
this actually makes some predictions
okay if we could vary the task
complexity by varying the duration of
the reach right then it says that
dimensionality should vary linearly with
time you know given that this if this
upper bound is indeed a tied upper bound
now we can't really vary the reach but
what we can do is we can look at
different epochs of time during the
reach and just keep the amount of time
or the amount of duration of data we
wish to analyze
we keep that variable okay all right the
second prediction is if you vary the
number of neurons in the data set
dimensionality should remain unchanged
this suggests that if we drop maybe 30
to 40 to 50 percent of the neurons will
essentially have a data set that
explores the same amount of
dimensionality it's which is kind of a
striking striking prediction Krishnas
lab members did not believe that when I
told them that prediction so any case so
so the prediction number one bears out
to be true if you analyze different
epochs of data and you plot the the
duration of the data set against its
dimensionality you see an almost linear
rise and it hugs the upper bound set by
a theory fortunately no data points are
on this side otherwise we're in big
trouble that means our theorem is wrong
but any case and then prediction number
two we can drop almost all you know we
can drop sixty percent of the neurons in
the data set and and essentially there's
no change in the dimensionality of the
data set okay so that was the most
boring part of the talk that the next
most interesting part is really the
shape right because you know the
dimensionality is roughly how many
dimensions you explore but we make
scientific inferences based on the shape
of these trajectories so under what
conceivable situation could we imagine
that we record an infinitesimal fraction
of neurons and we get the shape correct
ie that the shape would not change if we
reported many many more neurons so a
simple example just to gain intuition
the simplest system we can visualize is
a a brain with three neurons right and
for whatever reason it could be the
simplicity of the task or constraints or
neural dynamics the set of neural
activity patterns explored throughout
the experiment lay on a one dimensional
curved manifold of this form okay and
let's say this curved manifold is in
some sense randomly oriented or
distributed across neurons that it makes
sense that it doesn't matter and we
don't get to record all three neurons
right we only get to record two neurons
so let's say so then it's sort of
intuitively clear that it doesn't matter
which subset of two neurons we record
we'll get the right answer in some sense
in the sense that we'll only get to see
a shadow of this furled neural activity
patterns across the entire brain onto
the subset of neurons we record and the
geometry of the shadow is the same or
independent of which two subsets of
neurons we record and is similar to the
geometry of the full manifold of course
things may not be that good you know we
could be in a situation where that this
neural manifold is access aligned with
respect to the single neuron axes or
more simply neuron 2 is doing all the
work therefore in order to recover the
neural manifold any subset of neurons
that we record better include neuron 2
otherwise we're in big trouble ok so the
take-home messages when patterns of
neural activity are distributed across
neurons or you or the manifold of neural
activity patterns is randomly oriented
with respect to the single neuron axes
then we might be able to get away with
large amounts of subsampling but we need
to make this much more quantitative than
I have made it so far but the way that
we can do that is that this idea makes a
conceptual connection between something
electrophysiologists have been doing for
years and years and something that
machine learning people and applied
mathematicians have been doing also for
four years but fewer years right which
is the following what this says is that
the act of measuring a random subset of
neurons is equivalent to an experiment
that we cannot yet do which is measure
and random linear combinations of all
neurons in the circuit so imagine you
have a magical electrode that has a
linear combination of weights that
touches all the neurons in circuit and
spits out a linear combination of firing
rates and then you have another magic
electrode that does the same but a
different random linear combination and
then you build up a Mathon okay why are
these two equivalent this experiment is
like projecting the neural activity
pattern onto a coordinate subspace
whereas this experiment is like
projecting the neural activity pattern
onto a randomly oriented subspace the
two are equivalent if the neural
manifold is randomly oriented with
respect to single neuron axes to begin
with the advantage of thinking about it
this way is that we can exploit the
theory of
random projections to come up with a
theory of neurophysiology and the way we
think about this so I need to review
something about the mathematics of
random projections so actually if you're
interested in learning more I forgot the
reference but I forgot to cite myself
this is a review from an annual reviews
of neuroscience that I wrote with hime
you know in 2012 but the basic idea is
this is a this is a problem that shows
up in lots of fields is that all of the
interesting signals that we might care
about although they live in a very high
dimensional ambient space they may be
concentrated on a lower dimensional
curved manifold right so imagine that
you have an n-dimensional space this is
n is the number of neurons in the entire
brain region that could be order 10 to
the seventh for example and you project
it down to an M dimensional space which
could be a hundred dimensional the
number of neurons that you record the
interesting neural activity patterns
live on a k-dimensional subspace in this
ambient n dimensional space and the
natural question you'd like to ask is
when will the geometry of this manifold
be preserved when you project it down to
a randomly oriented subspace and the
measure of of preservation is just the
geometric distance so for example if SA
and SB are two points on the manifold in
the high dimensional space and a is the
projection matrix that maps you from
this space to this space so a SI + asbr
the distance in the low dimensional
space this measure is the fractional
error in the in the in the length
between the two points and what we'd
like is we'd like the worst case
distortion the maximal distortion over
all pairs of points in the manifold to
be less than something less than an
epsilon which where epsilon should be
small that's what we would like and the
question is how big do we have to make m
or the dimensionality of the subspace of
the number of recorded neurons and the
answer is as long as m and so this is a
paper by richard brown you can and and
wake in the 2007 they had some constants
in well well we're rewriting this paper
and but anyways but we have a tighter
version of this but and we're about to
submit that but any case the basic idea
is as long as the number of recorded
neuron
is one over epsilon squared times the
intrinsic dimensionality of the manifold
so for example in a reach on a cylinder
K would just be two times the logarithm
of the volume of the manifold times its
curvature then the worst case distortion
will be order epsilon with high
probability over the random choice of
the projection or in our application the
random subset of neurons that you're
going to record okay so just to
translate this volume times curvature
thing remember one over correlation
length is like curvature and the
numerator of neural task complexity was
like volume and so when you translate it
the same measure that upper bounded
dimensionality shows up again as a
theory of neural measurement in a theory
of neural measurement it tells you that
to achieve a certain distortion the
number of neurons you need to record
should be one over the distortion
squared times some constant times the
logarithm of the neural task complexity
plus another additive constant so now
this makes a striking prediction in
neural data which let me walk you
through the logic behind the prediction
and then what will test that prediction
so it's it says the following so what we
can do is we can vary both sides of this
equation right and look at ISO contours
of the distortion and they should be
straight lines so again I can vary the
complexity of the task by varying the
duration of data that I choose to
analyze so that's this axis okay so what
I can do is I can for example pick
different amounts of data and now I
can't record all the neurons in the
brain for the most complex task possible
but what I can do is I can take all my
recorded neurons and then I can sub
sample them I can reduce the number of
neurons and then here what I can do is I
can perform principal components
analysis to recover neural trajectories
and I can compare I can compute the
distortion that I get when I sub sample
neurons relative to what I get if I keep
all the neurons that I have access to
and then so at each point in this in
this plane I can compute the expected
distortion and what this theory says is
that the the ISO contours of constant
distortion should be straight lines
on an axis where the horizontal axis is
the logarithm of time or the logarithm
of neural task complexity and the
vertical axis is the number of neurons I
keep in the data so for example I could
allow myself to be more generous right
for the same task complexity I could
record more neurons and I would get a
lower distortion but again if I
proportionately reduced these that the I
so Contra of distortion should be a
straight line that should be parallel to
this same that this higher ISO contour
so basically this is a remark is a very
non-intuitive prediction that we can
make a neural data so we can test this
in neural data now this test is not
going to be actually let's just let's
just test it right now
of course I wouldn't be up here if it
didn't work out but or I'd be talk about
something else if this didn't work out
in any case this is what we get so we
varied the neural task complexity so
this is in logarithmic axis and we
varied the number of neurons and we
computed the distortion that you get in
these neural trajectories by losing
neurons and we find that the ISO
contours are indeed straight lines okay
so this wasn't an empty mathematical
test of a theorem that's already been
proved it's really a test that the
neural data satisfies the assumptions
underlying the theory and what were
those assumptions the assumptions were
that the manifold of neural activity
patterns explored by the monkey during
these reaches was randomly oriented with
respect to the single neuron axes and
indeed they do turn out to be randomly
oriented enough such that random
projections constitute an excellent
theoretical model of the process of
subsampling neurons or doing a lot doing
large-scale electrophysiology so so
that's great so let me just summarize
the take-home messages so far so
whenever we try to measure the
complexity of the data set by measuring
its it's its neural dimensionality we
should always compare it to its upper
bounds set by this neural task
complexity if the upper bound is close
to the neural task complexity then the
dimension out of your data set is
constrained by your task and the
smoothness of neural activity patterns
if it's much less than and only if it's
much less than then have you
additional intrinsic dynamic constraints
in the data above had beyond task
complexity and smoothness it could for
example originated from Ural Network
dynamics and also neural measurement
reveals an optimistic message
subsampling can indeed recover accurate
dynamic portraits
when neural activity patterns are highly
distributed and actually it says that to
recover dynamic portraits for more
accurately recover dynamic portraits
from more complex experiments where you
increase the complexity of the task you
may not need many more neurons to record
the number of neurons should go
logarithmically with your neural task
complexity measure the trick will be as
you do more and more complex tasks
exploring the behavioral space and get
dense behavioral sampling will be much
much tougher so that suggests that as we
design more and more complex neural you
know recording mechanisms we would want
to place a premium on the stability of
recording rather than recording many
many more neurons that will be much more
useful as neuroscience move four moves
forward to attack more complex tasks
okay so so everything that I've talked
about so far is fantastic ok so that was
the second most boring part of the talk
this is actually what I view is the most
interesting no I'm actually not joking
I've been doing this for a little bit so
it's boring to me now but anyways but
but but why was that the second most
boring part it's because we were looking
at trial average data right everything
was about trial average data what we'd
like to understand is neural circuit
computation on single trials right now
what happens on single trials the monkey
will do things or or any animal will do
things or think things that you didn't
tell it to do and those things might be
extremely interesting it might be
attentional fluctuations they might be
just thinking about other things they
they might be there might be unfortunate
confounds like pupil diameter right that
you're not measuring
but in any case what that will you know
as you do try as you look at trial
average neural data you average all that
out and you're left with that which is
reproducible across trials but we'd love
to understand the trial to trial
variability and so we'd like to have a
theory of a neural data analysis for
single trials and we've we've sort of
developed such a theory and I can't
possibly go through all of it in the
remain you know I wasn't planning on
going through it in the remaining talk
but I'm just gonna give you the
highlights so let's say that we we get
to record some of your some number of
neurons and you know when we do single
trial analyses when we try to decode
behavior on single trials or we try to
find latent subspaces you know what we
often do is we have a training data set
where we have say p trials and that's
precious experimental resources to
gather those that training data set so
let's say p or t is the number of
trading stimuli or amount of time that
we can record to build up a training
data set for subsequent single trial
data analysis and then the key issue of
course is the signal-to-noise ratio or
some measure of the traffic trial
reproducibility of your data and then we
have some measure of the complexity of
our experiment the questions we like to
ask is given these parameters how well
can we decode behavior in single trials
and how well can we learn the structure
of unobserved latent cognitive variables
for example like attentional
fluctuations that contribute to trial to
trial variability and we'd like again
such a theory to help us design
experiments before they're done so so we
have sort of three results along these
lines one is how well can we recover
late and cognitive subspaces how well
can we do single trial decoding for
nonlinearly embedded stimulus manifolds
and three the starting to come up with
what i like to call the rosetta stone
between dynamics and statistics how well
do statistical latent variable models
fit to a subset of neurons reflect the
dynamical properties of much larger
circuit I'll mostly talk about just this
stuff here so here's that here's the way
we kind of formalize the problem and
this formalization is still up for grabs
this is still relatively new so imagine
for example we're trying to infer some
kind of latent cognitive subspace so so
some latent subspace in which neural
activity is fluctuating because of
different things the animal is thinking
on different trials so imagine that the
subspace is K dimensional
right and let's say era is a subspace so
it's embedded in some n-dimensional
space of all neurons in the relevant
brain region that you don't get to
record the subspace you don't get to see
it directly you get noisy sampled
activity patterns that are off the
subspace so there could be other sources
of variability that are uncorrelated and
worse off you don't get to record all n
neurons you only get to measure a subset
of M neurons ok so you have an N and
neurons and you only get you don't have
you only get to observe P stimuli right
so you only you only get to observe or P
trials right so so for what values of
the number of recorded neurons the total
number of neurons in the brain the
number of trials you have available the
complexity of the subspace and the
signal-to-noise ratio can we correctly
recover the subspace in its
dimensionality I'm going to skip all the
details but the way we formalize it is
that as a low rank matrix denoising
problem we work out the random matrix
theory for it we get some complicated
formulas and they they simplify I'm
actually gonna these actually work with
experiments they actually simplify
believe it or not they simplify in the
relevant limit where the number of
require okay so what you need of course
is the number of trials better exceed
the complexity of your subspace or its
dimensionality the number of neurons
better exceed the subspace and once you
have those your signal-to-noise ratio X
employ them gives you a further
constraint the product of the
signal-to-noise ratio times the square
root of the number of recorded neurons
in the number of trials better also
exceed the dimensionality of your
subspace so what this suggests and and
it turns out there's a sharp transition
across this equality line what this
suggests is that there's a very
different experimental resources can be
traded off against each other so for
example this this tells you that there's
sort of a phase transition in a plane
formed by the number of trials and the
number of neurons such that if you're on
the correct side of the phase transition
you correctly recover the dimensionality
of the lane
cognitive subspace and you correctly
recover the orientation of the subspace
but if you're on the wrong side then
you're then you're in trouble okay
now this is really intriguing because
this suggests a trade-off between two
very different experimental resources
the number of recorded neurons and the
number of samples it's really the
product of the two that matters okay so
we tested this again in data from the
Shenoy lab and you know we made various
assumptions in our theories so we broke
all the assumptions by by just applying
it to data it's not necessarily clear
that the data will satisfy all the
assumptions in our theory but we
suspected that it would because of
something known as universality and
random matrix theory which is a
technical point which I shouldn't get
into but here's the basic idea so what
we did was we applied this to Gaussian
you know an algorithm known as Gaussian
process factor analysis that's designed
to do exactly what the theory was
designed to analyze which is to extract
a subspace just in an unsupervised
fashion from neural activity while the
monkeys reaching and you know again we
can't record from all the neurons in the
motor cortex as amazing as Krishna is he
can't do that
or his graduate students and postdocs
can't do that Krishna probably could
actually a but in any case we have a
hundred neurons right so what we do is
we reduce the number of neurons in our
data set and we reduce the number of
trials that go into the analysis and we
compare the subspace and its
dimensionality that we got with the
reduced experimental resources to what
we would get if we had all the
experimental resources so here we should
get you know good very good recovery but
what you see are sort of faint outlines
of a hyperbolic phase transition
boundary whereas where if the product of
the number of neurons a number of trials
that go into the analysis is above a
certain threshold then you're fine you
sort of correctly recover the subspace
and this holds despite the fact that
it's real neural data and the details of
the neural data neural statistics don't
necessarily conform to the detailed
statistical assumptions we made in our
analysis which I didn't really have time
to go
let me just advertise another thing
right so oftentimes we're interested in
decoding low dimensional manifolds of
stimuli or predicting neural responses
to low dimensional manifolds of stimuli
where we don't necessarily know tuning
curves ahead of time right so what we go
what we get to do is we get to showpiece
stimuli to the brain and we get noisy
patterns out and we'd like to ask for a
new stimulus that we've never seen
before how well will be will we be able
to predict the stimulus how does that
depend on the number of trials and the
SNR and so on and this is really pretty
thing say a single neuron for example so
we have a theory for that involving
nonlinear Gaussian processes and all
that and I'll skip the details actually
I'll just tell you the take-home message
this same neural task complexity measure
again shows up as long as the number of
trials is close to the neural task
complexity your fraction of explained
variance will become close to one so
what really matters is the ratio of the
number of trials to neural task
complexity so the same measure that
played a role in trial average data
analysis theory also plays a role in
single trial data analysis theory and
just to advertise this is sort of the
match in prediction performance on data
from météo care and Dinis lab where they
basically had they basically had 96
simultaneous recorded units and and they
measured the responses to oriented
gratings and this is sort of the
prediction performance predicted by a
theory as we vary the number of trials
and this is what we actually get from
the neural data very nice much and I'll
skip the last part on this rosetta stone
between dynamics and statistics and let
me just end with acknowledgments so
again hey Ron gouge did the lion's share
of the work the work in my lab and an
Eric Troutman also was involved in this
work and again I'd like to thank my
funding sources I just started tweeting
which is kind of embarrassing
I don't know why it's embarrassing
either because I just started or because
I started at all but anyways I sometimes
say random things okay thanks